before you begin make sure you have
scissors the GFP template and tape cut
out the 12 strips of paper outlined in
dotted lines representing the 11 beta
strand and one helical region of the GFP
tip together the strips so that the
letter on the white background for
example a is taped on top of the same
letter on the shaded background repeat
this four letters B through K
the long strip of paper from amino to
carboxyl the primary structure of GFP
regions of secondary structure beta
strands and alpha helixes are marked lay
the Strand labeled a on the table so
that the arrow is pointing upwards place
strand B to the right of a and orient it
so that the arrow points to the bottom
align the gray areas between the strands
representing the hydrogen bonds between
them and tape top to bottom on the
aligned gray area
next tape strands see next to be D next
to C and so on until strand K in each
case aligning the gray areas between the
strands and making sure the arrows and
these strands point up and down
alternately
at the end of the step the beta-sheet
should have strands labeled a through K
reading from left to right
make sure the chromophore strip is
behind the printed side of the beta
sheet
close the GFP beta-barrel by aligning
the gray areas between strands a and K
and taping them together the chromophore
should be inside the barrel